joining me here on the rich eisen show
big fan of this man's work it's a
pleasure to chat with uh with you here
stanley tucci four-time emmy award
winner whose new show la fortuna is now
on amc plus with new episodes being
released weekly on thursdays good to see
you sir nice to see you too thanks so
let's get just jump uh straight into
this series and uh what it's about and
what you want people to know if they uh
if they are not familiar with this show
just yet well yeah i mean it's it's a
six-part series that's based on uh sort
of based on a true story but sort of it
was kind of loosely based on true story
uh and it was a graphic novel from which
it came to
um
it uh about a guy who is a treasure
hunter
in in the vein of uh a sort of
contemporary um
indiana jones
which is how he sees himself
towards the end we realize that maybe
that's not really who he is it's not
quite that um
uh moral
right and so
basically the story of this there's this
this gold from this shipwreck a spanish
ship uh that that sank you know 500
years ago and um
uh he
figures out where it is
and then is going to keep it and the
spanish government
says wait a minute that's ours
uh and it becomes this
this
this sort of war between them
uh of who's going to be able to keep
that gold and it becomes quite litigious
and um emotional
and so what attracts you to something
like this when it's placed in front of
you where you say
okay i'll i'll do that
i've never played a character like that
i thought it was really
interesting i thought he was really
interesting and he was very complicated
and
and um
he had a lot of good in him
but the circumstances allowed the
the not so good in him to
come to the surface
and so do you have uh like a an interest
in in real life in
you know these sorts of i guess baubles
or
trinkets or whatever you're you're
looking for in this i'm fascinated yeah
i'm fascinated by articles by i'm
fascinated by archaeology
and i'm fascinated by anything that um
in fact well i live in london so there's
a thing that you do in london or that's
that some of us do yeah sort of nerdier
ones
like me we
go
mud locking
and mud locking is where you walk along
the foreshore of the of the thames
and you find whatever the
river decides to
to give you or you know
uh
and it's fascinating because london is
so old founded by the romans
uh that people find anything from roman
times to
uh saxon uh the saxon uh early uh viking
swords trinkets uh all the way through a
victorian era
uh
it's it's kind of incredible what you'll
end up finding in the tent
okay so you're walking the thames
and
some
[Music]
uh i guess ancient treasure of some sort
will just be in the mud like what have
you found yeah yeah you find mostly uh
you find a lot of clay pipes that date
from a whole bunch of different eras
and because clay pipes were basically
they were they were they were just
disposable right like like a cigarette
um so
when they so they then people use them
for you know a couple hundred years so
you find you always find pieces of clay
pipe and you find it even in soil
like the soil that they'll use to fill
your
garden your backyard if you dig in
you're definitely going to find pieces
of
tile crockery pottery you're going to
find definitely pieces of pipe
either the bowl of the pipe or the stem
of the pipe
and you know that you find beautiful
glass bottles you'll find
belt buckles you'll find you know people
find swords people find everything
swords
this is yeah i'm talking about like
viking swords there was just uh uh there
was somebody who found a they believe
was a viking sword in in putney which is
the next about
two miles down the road uh i'm telling
it's kind of incredible what what they
what they uncover so what do you do just
go on go on the internet just look up
mud larking okay and there's a woman
named laura maklin and she
um she's like sort of the the the queen
of the of the mud larks she's written a
couple books about it and it's very
beautiful her first book is really
beautiful
um but it's that it's that kind of stuff
that digging back into history that i
find fascinating and that's one of the
reasons why la fortuna to me was really
interesting so they they found the right
four-time emmy award-winning mud locker
for
for this project is that what you're
saying stanley without a question yeah i
do it i kick my son my son he's seven we
go down and
just down the river's right here just
half a block away so we go down when the
tide is low
a little stinky go figure that okay well
that's something i did not know which
kind of uh plays into something that i
do here on my show with celebrity guests
like yourself is a celebrity true or
false
where uh we see things about your career
that's been written
and uh actually place in front of you to
see if you can confirm whether
something's true or false if you don't
mind playing a lot no no yeah go ahead
here we go here's celebrity true or
false with stanley tucci
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
first up uh true or false stanley tucci
you are roommates with a certain irving
reigns
at suny purchase and you were the first
to start calling him ving is that true
or false
uh yeah and yes i was definitely the
first star poem thing yeah because i was
i didn't understand
the fact that his
name was it seemed it didn't seem to
suit him yes the name irving
and i said
i and i just started calling him thing
and he goes i like that
and so that was that and that was that
yeah i think he legally changed it
so um did you just move into the dorms
and he was there or did you no no no we
were in the same class at uh you know it
was you had companies the school we went
to was suny at purchase which was a
conservatory
and and basically you had to audition to
get in and they chose a group of 30
people for each year and you stayed with
those 30 people there were cuts
periodically so eventually it dwindled
down to like 18 people or something like
that uh and
so he was in the class with me and
so we were together we were at school
for four years together right so then
you just we're roommates and now he's
known as ving rhames and that is cause
for you because you were the one who's
decided to shorten his name how about
that i did not know that yeah i know
there you go well done sir well done uh
true or false your first on-camera job
was in a levi's commercial is that true
or false um
yeah i think i think that was the first
time i was ever on camera i'm not quite
sure probably okay yeah
what did you do in this commercial i
just walked down the street towards the
camera it was this whole series of
commercials that
that were done in the 80s for levi's
they were really
great commercials and
and just people they would just pick
people you know you'd go in and they'd
say they'd
just talk to you and then
they might call you to be in the
commercial and all you did was walk down
the street or stand on a street corner
or whatever did you get to keep they
were very hip and cool all these long
lenses and yeah did you get to keep the
pants stanley did you
i kept the pants okay okay yeah
like uh like i said i made a few hundred
bucks and kept the pants very good and
things clearly worked out which leads me
and then my next uh true or false
because it involves meryl streep so
clearly things worked out for you after
the levi's commercial um uh true or
false uh we already know you're a
lifelong foodie i want to get into that
a little bit more you made meryl streep
cook with you before shooting julia and
julia is that true or false
yes true
yeah yeah because i felt like we needed
to be in the kitchen together and we
were both
busy
and it was
it was hard to sort of get everybody's
schedule together you know
and then um i said well don't you think
we need to just get in the kitchen
together just once just to kill it out i
go i don't want to be too messy you know
but
and she goes yeah yeah all right all
right so so we we so we got into the
kitchen and we and we had well we just
had the best time
what'd you make do you remember uh
blanquette devoe
we cooked from one of julia's from the
the art of french cooking
uh uh and um
we made blanca devoe
which you know like a lot of those
recipes incredibly rich
uh and then merrill made a tart tattoo
it was really good i tried to make some
vegetable thing that didn't work okay so
it was award-winning because she was
doing it is that basically it does she
is she award-winning cook just because
it's
okay it goes without saying i don't mean
to be you know she gets every award yeah
pretty much yes uh true or false you're
john kravinci uh john krasinski's
brother-in-law is that true or false
stanley
you'll have to ask our wives yes yes
yeah i am yeah
are you aware that that shocked
everybody when that got on the instagram
i just
are you aware of that
well i mean it's pretty obvious if i'm
married to emily's sister then he would
be my brother-in-law
i mean it's not that complicated no i
know that but i i it's i i i guess you
know you hear the last names and you
don't put two and two together but it's
kind of just
what what is
they're going to be here yeah they're
going to come
they're going to be here they're going
to stay with us for
a bit
so that's nice yeah people kind of
flipped out about that when they when
they kind of heard about it um so i
guess this makes this next one
pretty wild too because um the the
connection that through line is devil
wears prada um is it true that you
joined the cast the weekend before
shooting your first day on a monday is
that a true story right there stan uh
not quite that quick but
yeah
just about i mean i didn't have a lot of
time let's put it that way they were
already
filming yeah i mean the the fact that
you then you know met your wife through
this i mean that is kind of you know um
kismet right that you're
that you joined the cast late and then
all of a sudden you had a big
you know life moment for yourself well
yeah i did i mean i i you know i
joined the cast
and i knew merrill just
socially
and then um we
uh jonathan i didn't know emily and
emily and i became friends
and then um
after
that and i was married at the time my
wife was my late wife still alive
and uh you know emily and i stayed
friends
throughout and then when i went to
emily's wedding i met her sister and we
had met once before at the devil awards
broader premiere and then i was coming
to england and um
to do captain america and i said well
why don't
you know let's go out to dinner
so we went out to dinner and then we got
married
not that fast there you go and there you
go that is incredible and then you know
obviously food is such an important part
of
you know what how people know you
uh your series that you have done
recently um
searching for italy stanley tucci
searching for italy i i have to tell you
personally my wife and i
adore this show thank you and um i'm
sure you've heard this
a lot that you helped people get through
the pandemic
something like this right like i know
yeah is that i assume you've heard that
a lot i have heard that and i'm i'm
happy that
i could do something because we were all
so helpless let's face it the people
really were excited
uh aren't we're excited about and are
excited about the show and yes it i
think it did
you know it
they could sort of live vicariously
through us
um
and
no it was nice i mean also we had a
captive audience let's face it
it felt like we did go somewhere though
you know what i mean yeah yeah well
that's what you want i mean but maybe if
we
if there hadn't been a pandemic we
wouldn't have had as many viewers but
anyway it worked out so where where is
the best
pasta dish
in italy stanley tucci i know that
yeah
can't do that not a question
you're not a question because there's no
answer
there is no answer for that
it could be
carbonara in rome it could be
uh
the
spaghetti zucchini uh
zucchini alone
[Music]
it could be it could be a million it
could be anything i know i shouldn't i
should know better than to have asked
that question but i thought maybe
maybe there was an answer no i don't
know
well that's i guess that's why there is
a season two of this show right coming
up yes coming out in march fantastic i
should because uh my wife and i
one of the best pasta dishes we've ever
had in italy i've been married uh 18
years uh was when we were driving on our
honeymoon
from milan
down to rome yeah and we stopped off to
you know fill up with gas at a gas
station
in outside of bologna and found this
restaurant called trey galetti
and just said all right we'll try it it
looked you know it wasn't a strip mall
it was one of the best pasta dishes i've
ever had my entire life yeah there's no
telling it is the weirdest it is like
the weirdest thing in the world
i mean sometimes you'll get like a great
piece of pizza like like you say like a
gas station and
you're just like what there's nothing or
a pasta or like you go and there's a
little restaurant attached to the gas
station and you'll have rabbit
you know and you're like wow what and
that what oh my gosh and then of course
you've got taste my life through food
which is a
book that's available now wherever you
can get your books so
um you know truly um
uh appreciate your time and your work
stanley tucci and then let's fortuna uh
amc plus where new episodes being
released weekly on thursdays
congratulations on that thank you so
much absolutely i'd love to do this
anytime you want to just
shoot the breeze about food or anything
going on in your career i barely touched
on on your your film and television
career so great thanks to you sir oh
thank you so much and i do hope you get
to go to the scolio you know what um
i've seen the photographs i i i came
very close you know the whole covert
thing knocked me out but i know i'm so
sorry my wife is determined to go there
you're gonna go you're gonna go there
you're going to go there and you're
going to have the best time right and i
have to plan that's like a five-hour
deal right something like that isn't
that or what the food no just the whole
experience just to hang there right no
well you can stay there
right so they have
rooms they have rooms upstairs and
they're really simple it's nothing fancy
at all
but it's just so lovely and the people
are so nice
that is so great that's what i would do
stay there for a night or two it's just
there you go done thank you stanley
tucci everybody watch la fortuna on amc
amc plus thanks for joining me here on
the show thanks a lot
see you later
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here